let's talk a little bit about conspiracy
theories and fear-mongering and using
fear as a tool to influence we're going
to look at one of the usual suspects
Tulsi gabbard but we're also going to
look at a guy named this I hesitate Dr
John Campbell not a medical doctor and
relevantly not a medical doctor in a
second segment this may surprise some of
you but we will get to that let's start
with and the theme Here is using fear
and and you know irritating and scaring
people agitating and scaring people
Tulsi gabbard was on Fox news's The Five
yesterday and Tool c i I know that the
word is now in the in the the Lexicon
sanctimoniously
bemoaned the use of fear to manipulate
people and of course Tulsi herself is
one of the people who has used fear to
manipulate people particularly since
coming out against the Democratic Party
and becoming an anti-vaccine anti-trans
spokesperson of sorts so let's start as
it makes sense to do
listening to what gabbard herself said
and then we'll talk about why it's
particularly Rich that she make this
claim does anybody ever get
held for any wrongdoing it's it's
frightening that the answer to that is
probably no at this point they can
continue to lie one of the things that I
I took away from the statement that
gorsuchets wrote was gorsets here that
he used covet as the example but really
what we know throughout history going
back to the cold war in the Post 9 11
now this new cold war is that when we
have people in positions of power
fomenting fear it makes it easier for
them to take away our freedoms and so
the big warning signal kind of the red
alert for everyone is as soon as you
start to see people in power over hyping
a situation or a threat fomenting fear
we have to go back and remember Benjamin
Franklin's famous quote right that those
who would give up essential Liberty to
purchase a little temporary Safety and
Security deserve neither security nor
Liberty wow sad poignant words from
Tulsi gabbard now of course Tulsi has
done a campaign for a while now
portraying herself as the victim of the
fear-mongering by by the Democratic
establishment where people said oh tool
sees a wolf in sheep's clothing
Tulsi is one of the great practitioners
of fear-mongering to influence and
manipulate herself and she uses the
fear-mongering as a tool to advance her
interests and her Ambitions she wants to
be seen and unfortunately some fell for
it and saw her as this principled
anti-war activist who will always expose
the lies of the fear mongers and the war
mongers but in in reality she has turned
out to be and I want to be accurate a
pro-authoritarian
conspiratorial fear-monger who actually
has fomented the very fear and division
among Americans that she pretends to go
after when she has called Democratic
leaders War mongers who will get us into
whether it's World War four or five or
nuclear Armageddon
that was fear-mongering that made no
sense and was not factually based in any
way check out her appearance on the Joe
Rogan program rather than ever
addressing the substantive criticisms of
her foreign policy views or explain why
did you meet with Syrian dictator Bashar
al-assad in 2017 she simply uses fear to
portray herself as this persecuted
almost whistleblower who was exposing
the corruption of the establishment and
if people ask too many questions about
why she met with that dictator then next
thing you know it'll be 1984. she has
said that whistleblowers and dissenters
were being silenced by the government
and that therefore we all need to worry
about eroding democracy and freedom with
no real substantive criticism of the way
that the Trump Administration
single-handedly made a free press the
enemy of the people which actually is
something that we should be afraid of
and of course it's always is without
specifics about who is it exactly that's
doing any of this stuff and there's so
many examples in October of 2022 she
posted a video on Instagram which
accused the Democratic party of stoking
anti-white racism and undermining law
enforcement when the reality is that
police have not been defunded and that
the so-called divisive agenda of
Democrats on race it's mostly a reaction
to the outrageous anti-woke stuff from
the right but that's not what she tells
you she just makes you afraid of the
Democrats and the things that they're
going to do and we could go on you know
when she spoke at CPAC
um she fear-mongered about how the Biden
vaccine mandates and so-called lockdowns
were attacks on civil liberties and
personal freedoms the likes of which we
will never recover from and it will be a
slippery slope into woke a stand or
whatever ignoring the public health
benefits ignoring scientific evidence
and all these things she wants to
sanctimoniously go after those who use
fear when it's hard to imagine someone
who has used fear more than Tulsi
herself so there's that let's now go to
another sort of example of this uh Dr
John Campbell